on ne vous demande pas de dire oui mais
simplement de vous poser la question en
cas d'accident seriez vous prêt oui ou
non à donner vos organes c'est le thème
de la journée nationale de réflexion
lancée aujourd'hui 30 % les français
refusent encore l'idée d'un prélèvement
d'organes alors que les espagnols ne
sont que 15%
il faut dire que le pays s'est mobilisé
que le système prélèvements greffe
fonctionne beaucoup mieux reportage à
barcelone nathalie sa peña valérie lucas
sous ce drap stérile un grain prélever
cette heure auparavant précieux organe
veiller en permanence par un médecin est
maintenue en fonctionnement par une
machine
le temps que les analyses confirment
qu'il est bon a transplanté précautions
maximales le donneur avait 76 ans les
reins des gens de 60 ou 70 ans
parfois même de 80 ans fonctionne aussi
bien ils ne vont pas durer vingt ans
mais huit ou douze ans la même espérance
de vie qu'un receveur aj prélevés sur
des personnes de plus en plus âgés c'est
l'une des voies pour accroître le nombre
d'organes en espagne 40 % les donneurs
ont plus de 60 ans seulement 20% en
france voici l'hôpital clinic de
barcelone
l'un des plus gros centres de
transplantation espagnol ici le service
de coordination a été créée en 1984
ces moyens sont énorme comparé aux
hôpitaux français neuf médecins à plein
temps une organisation rigoureuse deux
fois par jour ils font le tour des
unités de soins intensifs à la recherche
de donneurs se sont eux aussi qui
interviendront auprès de la famille swim
spas cinq mondes
il est très important de faire la
différence entre le médecin qui soigne
le malade et qui déclare le décès et le
médecin qui va faire la demande de don
d'organes
les coordinateurs de prélèvement sont
spécialisés dans les entretiens avec la
famille cette professionnalisation du
prélèvement d'organes repose sur la
générosité des espagnols il affiche le
taux de refus le plus bas du monde 15 %
contre 32 % en france à l'image de ces
deux femmes qui ont réagi sans hésiter
lors du décès soudain de leur mère quel
organe avez vous donné tous les yeux
enfin les cornées le coeur le foie les
reins tounes c'est pas facile et ça se
passe mal mais après petit à petit tu te
rends compte que tu as bien fait c'était
ce qu'est le mal est et que beaucoup de
personnes peuvent vivre et voir grâce à
ses organes le modèle espagnol s'exporte
partout dans le monde même en france
ici à cergy pontoise le mois dernier le
docteur marty magna ligue de barcelone
étaient venus former 40 médecins
français son message les organistes il
faut savoir les trouver et cela
s'apprend quand elles sont plus
entraîner un peu de connaissance des
résultats est je crois que les espagnols
ont effectivement moins de scrupules a
posé la question j'ai besoin d'organes
ils sont plus habitués ils font plus
insisté auprès de la famille chez lui
dans un certain nombre de cas il faut le
dire
les personnels ne sont pas toujours très
à l'aise avec cette question objectif de
la france faire aussi bien que l'espagne
34 prélèvements par million d'habitants
contre 23 actuellement un impératif car
la demande d'organes ne cesse
d'augmenter partout dans le monde